I want you to look in my eyes
I guarantee you I guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel they want to do
the same thing I want to do they want to
phase out fossil fuels and we're going
to phase out fossil fuels Joe Biden
wasn't kidding about ending fossil fuels
and now he's coming for your car the
White House turbo charging its radical
green agenda by unveiling their toughest
restrictions yet they will force you to
buy an expensive electric vehicle
whether you like it or not the new rules
Target tailgate emissions and the goal
is to have 67 percent of new vehicles to
be electric by 2032. keep this in mind
only six percent of cars sold last year
were electric but there's a big problem
Americans don't want them just 19 say
that they are very likely to buy an EV
and hey it's no wonder the average EV
costs forty thousand dollars or more but
Biden's people say it will actually
saved you money
we're going to save consumers money you
know these vehicles don't require as
much maintenance obviously the gas
prices are a little steeper and electric
vehicles will be cheaper over the
lifespan and like all things Joe Biden
China is the big winner here they own 75
percent of the world's lithium battery
lithium ion battery manufacturing
capacity however the EPA administrator
says don't worry about the commies
we have to walk and chew gum at the same
time this proposal doesn't kick in until
model year
2027. so we've got some years to ramp up
we hope that we can take advantage of of
that Runway and follow the Investments
of historic legislation to bring
manufacturing especially battery
manufacturing back here domestically
you know it's interesting Jesse that you
know they talk about bringing battery
manufacturing back here domestically
when these batteries have to be made in
China and as they make more of these
Lithium-ion batteries they're creating
more coal powered plants that have the
worst emissions and we suffer from that
in the long run yeah we dominate the oil
space China dominates the lithium space
And We Just Surrender and say okay China
you have all the power
Joe Biden doesn't own an electric car
his family doesn't Hunter doesn't Jimmy
the chin doesn't Frankie four fingers
silent Val and the naughty niece none of
them own electric I've checked and if
you're saying I'm going to shut down all
the power plants in the country at the
same time telling everybody to plug in
an electric car what's that going to do
to the grid judge boom it blows up the
Grid it's already fragile I don't like
the fact that he's forcing all Americans
to buy new technology Eisenhower didn't
make us all Buy TVs Barack Obama didn't
make us all buy iPhones why is he forced
Trump didn't make us all get electric
toothbrushes we just use our rotator
cuffs and do it on the cheap there's
really no reason for it I mean they're
forcing us to get a vaccine to wear
masks enough already with the forcing
let us choose what we want to do the
light bulbs don't get me started the gas
stoves don't get me started did you know
this statistic I found this out today
judge it's going to rock you electric
cars emit 20 tons of carbon before you
even drive them right that means there's
four years of driving before the thing
even gets off the lot so it's because of
all of the heavy machinery and
industrial production it takes to do
these things and then you plug it in and
then the grids run off what carbon China
dominates that stupid it's not going to
lower the Earth's temperature at all all
it does is make the donors happy because
this is a religion to them and it makes
my guys in Detroit happy because they
sell these things and we pay for half of
it it's the taxpayers subsidizing this
Green Revolution well the the
interesting thing is that the average
cost of an American gas powered car is
26 000. the average cost of an electric
car is sixty four thousand dollars so
how is this going to be cheaper for
Americans we already know we put 31
billion dollars Geraldo into sub
subsidies to boost EVS but it seems like
everybody but the ordinary person is
getting those boosts well I think that
as you've seen with Tesla judge the
prices are dropping I think that the
more or manufactured the greater the
pace of the the price drop I think will
become much more competitive I think
it's stunning when you look at the
transit how many it's only 60 of all
vehicles sold in the country but the
trend lines are straight up people are
buying it the market is dictating the
conversion from gas powered to
electricity
it is
a subsidy of 7 500 is not I was gonna
buy it I was going to buy an EB uh
Bentley my next my last car will be an
EV Bentley and they they offer me a 7
500 rebate I said I don't I don't need
this 7500 thank God you connect with our
audience okay but but the fact of the
when you see what is happening in terms
of the private sector people are buying
I mean we can score warned and coal
mines and lithium and all the rest of it
it is changing it is changing at a pace
more rapid than we ever anticipated uh
here's one thing
electric powered vehicles
have 60 efficiency in terms of the
conversion of energy to the wheels
turning gas powered is 17 to 21 electric
vehicles are three times more energy
efficient in terms of making your car go
then gas powered yeah but that alone is
enough to dictate this Monumental change
which is happening regardless well
apparently the message ain't getting out
because Americans don't want to buy them
but Dana there is also an increase in
premiums by insurers because the
batteries cannot be repaired and that
doesn't even deal with the fact that the
battery is as big as the chassis in the
bottom of the car and where are we going
to put it environmentally when the
battery dies well then they don't get
recycled this is you know great for
child laborers in Congo who get buried
alive trying to mine these
minerals for everybody who wants these
electric cars it's not only the donors
are happy because it's like they're
philanthropic or they care they're
actually they own these companies that
are getting and the the benefit from it
the other thing that happened is just
last week March 27th or I think that was
last week or two ago when I was on my
trip I would read this article in the
guardian about all these EU ministers
basically having to pull back because
they were trying to go too far too fast
with the mandates for electric vehicles
and Germany said hold on guys we we have
we shared the same goal we want to get
to a zero carbon future but you're
trying to make us go too fast the other
thing that happens and one of the
reasons that insurance premiums might go
up is are these cars lighter and if
these cars are lighter what does that
mean on the highway what about safety
and so there's a whole cost benefit
analysis and risk analysis that needs to
be done that will happen this is not
automatically going to happen but this
signals to all the industry that this is
where the government wants to go so they
start changing anyway you know Greg I
know you have very sophisticated taste
when it comes to cars you like older
cars I mean how how does it feel the
idea of you're driving the same car that
everybody else is driving do you get
bored at that thought
I'm trying to control myself why
because you said Evie Bentley and you
just explained why people like you find
it so easy to sermonize about electric
vehicles because you can afford it are
you attacking me yes I am attacking you
you deserve it but then I have to
counter-attack when you finish well no
the thing is what I'm pointing out is
you just said
to our audience right who has to pay for
the charging stations our audience right
who has to pay for the transition from
gas to electric stoves our audience
oh God you don't even have the science
to back that up you have to bear the
brunt of your beliefs and you don't
because you can afford an EV Bentley
we're telling you
what kind of cars do you drive when I
was in the news
yes yes your vintage cars yes a forty
five thousand dollar car yes yeah I know
it's no Bentley I'm sorry
you stepped in it I'll let I'll back off
you could not I'll back off I'm gonna
I'm gonna continue the green movement is
tied up in knots right now electric cars
exploit cheap human labor in Africa and
in China the climate predictions are
falling apart the smart folks are
flocking to nuclear and identity
politics stole the Thunder from the
climate agenda and how do you know that
you got to look at ESG right Equity
social governance why are they packed
together like that at companies it's
because you couldn't do climate on its
own because no one bought it so what
they did is they married it to race and
they married it to gender so if you come
out against ESG it's about you being a
bigot not about you being smart about
the climate none of their predictions
have come true none of them they are
fighting they're forcing America to do
this crap over one less than a percent
Celsius less than a percent Celsius it
has no effect and in fact as this
climate gets warmer people's lives
improve that's a fact that's a fact
people die from cold weather more
frequently than warm weather so give me
your cancer BS
when I moved to California you could not
see across the 405. the smog was so
thick thank God because of regulations
that the air is leaned up and now the
marketplace is driving the sales of BB I
predict that with the the marketplace
will go faster than the Elon Musk has
the right idea you make you make a car
that is attractive and appealing to
people and they'll go to it right don't
force people to do things you want to
force people because you can't afford
anything at me you can afford it don't
say Bentley hey coming up Democrats
proving themselves to be totally
clueless on crime and picking blood soak
Chicago for their 2024 convention I went
on Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now